[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here and today we're
exploring the bizarre antics of movie
stars / performance artists / internet
meme Shia LaBeouf
while Shia is perhaps best known for his
breakout role in even Stevens and his
later commercial successes it's been his
smaller projects and erratic off-screen
antics that have transformed him from a
movie star into a kind of meme artist
when the seagulls follow the trailer is
because they think sardines will be
thrown into the sea thank you very much
growing up is hard especially for child
actors and Shia is no exception
his life of Fame seems to have left him
with very few boundaries and an almost
masochistic love of self mockery when
musician Rob Cantor wanted to shoot a
music video for his song about a
rampaging cannibal known as Shia LaBeouf
Shia was not only willing to participate
but suggested he reenact the clapping
scene from Citizen Kane why does Shia
have his own entry on Know Your Meme com
it's just another actor like William
Shatner or Chuck Norris who's willing to
cash in on his fame through self parody
or something else going on here I went
through like a existential crisis uh-huh
which turned into some kind of like
exploration really welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
Shia LaBeouf for nearly a decade Shia
LaBeouf has bounced from one tabloid
scandal to another back in 2007 he was
arrested in a Chicago Walgreens on his
21st birthday I got pretty wasted in
Chicago a lot of celebrating in
Walgreens in 2011 he was recorded
getting in a fight outside a bar in
Vancouver but wasn't arrested and in
2014 after drinking a lot of whiskey so
I had been drinking a lot of whiskey
LaBeouf interrupted a performance of
cabaret by accosting Alan [ __ ] as he
was making his way to the stage he was
just wasted he blacked me he did say
that the reason he did it was that I was
a sexist man he'd ever seen so
but his most significant controversy
occurred when he plagiarized daniel
clothes comic just in M Damiano using it
as the basis for his 2012 short film
Howard can't or calm after Howard can't
or comprar mir-2 can it was released
online where fans of closed comic
inevitably found it and tore it apart
exposed LaBeouf needed an excuse to
explain himself first he tried to
explain the plagiarism as an act of
postmodern reappropriation claiming that
he was undermining the idea of
originality and authorship he's looking
to take his [ __ ] off my shoulders you
know so I found this discourse sort of
ran with that but that didn't really
work out so he tried to apologize but
that didn't cut it either at this point
Shia turned to an obscure art movement
called meta modernism for help
post-modernism meta modernism what the
hell's the difference let me explain an
easy way to grasp the difference between
post-modernism and meta modernism is to
think about Hollywood movies an example
of a postmodern movie would be Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool a film we've talked
about before I'm touching myself tonight
a traditional superhero like spider-man
believes in big ideas like justice
responsibility and truth with an
absolute sincerity this great power
comes great responsibility
Deadpool says [ __ ] all that be a hero
the way we there are no big ideas worth
believing in for the Merc with the mouth
the idea of truth and sincerity is just
a movie cliche to be lampooned
as he massacres bad guys for strictly
personal reasons okay guys let's get out
there and make a difference what about
meta modernism what the hell does that
if traditional Hollywood heroes embody
sincere values while postmodern heroes
fully reject such ideas then meta
modernist ones fall somewhere in between
a kind of sincerity that is communicated
to an insincere distancing confusing
yeah this stuff can get a bit nebulous
the best example of a meta modernist
movie would be harmony Corinne's batshit
crazy Spring Breakers
our heroes are for bikini clad girls on
a hedonistic rampage we follow them as
they plunge into sex drugs and
debauchery and yet despite the
over-the-top depravity of the party
scenes the girls describe their
experiences as a sincere process of
self-improvement and self-discovery
beautiful things here I mean everyone
was so sweet here so warm and friendly
juxtaposing the quasi spiritual tone of
the girls monologue with images of
indulgence or mass murder may seem
ironic met people who were just like us
was way more than just having a good
time but the girls epiphanies are a
hundred percent authentic in true meta
modernist fashion Spring Breakers uses
an ironic insincere approach to
communicate something absolutely serious
after spending months defending himself
online LaBeouf came to the realization
that neither clever jokes nor genuine
explanation would be good enough he
needed to do something that would show
everybody that he really was sorry he
needed to be vulnerable
I had read this meta modern manifesto
which really touched me so LaBeouf
created his first meta modernist artwork
entitled hash tag I am sorry a
performance art installation in LA where
he invited the public to join him in his
sorrow audience members were to enter
the mostly empty gallery pick out a prop
like an Indiana Jones with a bottle of
Jack Daniels a transformer and then sit
across from LaBeouf who was wearing that
infamous paper bag over his head he
wanted to show contrition
but like Spring Breakers he delivered
the apology so that the audience would
hold it at a distance making it not
entirely sincere but not entirely
insincere it's all the distance and
irony of post-modernism with all the
sincerity of a classic narrative most
didn't understand what they were seeing
or what it meant but definitely pretty
weird but encountering and apologizing
sometimes crying Shia LaBeouf in an LA
art gallery encountering a scene that
was both sincere and ironic at the same
time gave them a decidedly meta
modernist experience he was emotionally
pouring out the whole time and even if
they didn't understand it they felt it
everyone thinks he's so crazy but it
seemed like the least crazy thing I've
seen him do in a while the spectacle of
Shia didn't end with an apology instead
the hashtags and stunts kept coming and
in each case the performances were both
ironic and sincere at the same time his
meditation for narcissus an hour-long
session wherein LaBeouf jumped rope in
front of a mirror was both self-mocking
and truly meditated his work entitled
hashtag interview was both a
simple-minded stunt and an
along exploration of uncomfortable
intimacy his work hashtag touch my soul
was both ironic and sincere hi you've
reached LaBeouf Rothko and Turner can
you touch my soul and perhaps his most
memorable work hashtag introductions was
meant to be a shallow viral sensation
while simultaneously communicating true
feelings is impossible
hashtag introductions wasn't originally
meant to be an absurd version of a
motivational speech way but rather was a
collaborative film project created with
the help of 36 film students Shia and
his collaborators asked the students to
submit short monologues for LaBeouf to
read while standing in front of a green
screen
each monologue had to evoke a feeling
any feeling the students work was naive
and even sentimental yet LaBeouf's
performance in front of the green screen
was coldly calculated every time I see a
man on a motorbike I think it's my dad
the work was both a viral PR stunt and
entirely heartfelt and that's what meta
modernism is it's a mix of shallow
self-promotion and intimacy it's a
process where the bland and the
commercial is made uncomfortable and
even dangerous a meta modernist moment
is when what is designed to numb you
turns around breaks and makes you feel
something in a world where we're all
cynical we like to think that we can
hold ideas like Uncle Ben's famous line
about responsibilities at a distance
what meta modernism does is agree with
us it encourages us to be cynical but
then surprises us by making us feel the
guilt we would have felt if we had taken
Uncle Ben seriously LaBeouf's
performances aimed to make you take him
seriously he wants to take your cynicism
about his fame and persona and turn it
against you
Shia is like the girls from Spring
Breakers they to come off as trivial
people who don't have to be taken
seriously but they turn out to be very
dangerous and impossible to ignore so
what do you think is Shia LaBeouf a bold
new voice taking performance-art to the
next level or is he just a bored
celebrity pulling pranks on us all let
us know what you think in the comments I
know I can't single-handedly save the
world that I'd like to like try hey guys
thanks for watching remember we're
working on more videos like this one so
to find out when they're released
smack Alan [ __ ] sexy self to visit
our channel page and subscribe just do
wait
and if you find the stuff we make
interesting and insightful you're going
to love another channel called them
righter our buddy Evan over there
produces beautiful i opening video
essays all about understanding art
movies culture and so much more click
here to visit his channel page and
subscribe and since we're talking about
the unconventional go check out his
awesome video on creative title
sequences exploring the fascinating
world of film packaging how artists give
movies their iconic look in the opening
and closing credits it's pretty awesome
alright I gotta go work on the next
wisecrack edition which may or may not
feature a little bit more Rick and Morty
well to let a dub dub thanks again for
the support y'all peace